they'll give you pudding room yeah
you're going on cafeteria and they you
just swipe a garden they give you these
mud pudding as you want
was this your schedule yeah yeah what's
up with all this theater man well I'm a
theater major so yeah a cup of acting
bug pretty bad but yeah I already
auditioned for the the fall production
they miss Oh Rob that's cool so can you
like cry on command the stuff oh yeah
it's easy think of something really sad
real quick like a bundle of babies
exploding or like dogs exploding or like
like maybe your mom is really sick or
you like walked in on like her on her
rape you know I just stop but you can't
stop him because he's bigger than you
like you just think of that oh that hits
so close to home for me and my dog
actually exploded when I was a kid I'm
sorry I didn't mean to it's okay you are
a really good actor to think you're like
Sean William Scott you're at a Sean
William Scott love thank you thank you
well you know it's just living
truthfully and imaginary circumstances
and whatever enough about me what's
what's on your schedule
me women's sexuality sexual revolution
the human body remedial math the Bible
is literature
I'm doing that for my gf get the heck
out of here you already scored a
girlfriend no no if she's back in high
school were like crazy religious though
we always get on our knees and pray to
Jesus not orally you know protection
coming next we come we'll go see you at
God of that play dude that's not for a
while plus I already got cast it's like
a police officer I'm just in the
background I don't even have lines yeah
I know it's just a popularity contest
when you get down to it
oh man I'm like the most popular due to
my high school now that I've graduated
high school and I am throwing you a
party bro so you can infiltrate that
theater nerd crew like in Mean Girls yes
no I mean gross is my favorite movie
explain to the DVD special commentary
Lindsey
[Music]